Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Ecco un'immagine bellissima di Saturno,
presa dalla sonda Cassini nel 2013.
Questa è chiamata "The Pale Blue Dot":
È un selfie,
fatto a 1,5 miliardi di chilometri
di distanza dalla Terra:
oltre 3700 volte la distanza
della Terra dalla Luna.
Ma il primo selfie interplanetario
fu scattato dalla sonda Voyager uno,
il giorno di San Valentino del 1990;
e per quell'occasione,
l'astrofisico Carl Sagan scrisse:
"Da questo distante punto di osservazione,
la Terra può non sembrare
di particolare interesse.
Ma guardate bene, quel puntino.
È qui. È casa. Siamo noi.
Ogni essere umano che sia mai esistito
è vissuto lì, in quel minuscolo
granello di polvere."
E aggiungerei, un granello
un po' speciale:
speciale perché ci ospita.
E da quel minuscolo granello di polvere,
che è appunto la Terra,
per la prima volta
nella storia dell'umanità
siamo in grado di scoprire
la vita su altri pianeti.
Adesso state con me,
perché partiamo per un viaggio
che un po' comprende
un cambio di prospettiva,
un ribaltamento,
in cerca di un nuovo punto di vista
che ci permetta di capire
il nostro posto nell'universo.
Io sono una ricercatrice di astrofisica
e mi occupo di scoprire esopianeti,
che orbitano intorno ad altre stelle
che non sono il nostro.
"Eso-pianeti", perché appunto
sono fuori dal sistema solare.
Il cinque ottobre,
anzi il sei ottobre 1995,
ci fu una scoperta strabiliante.
Perché in un momento, praticamente,
cancellò tutte le nostre
conoscenze teoriche
sulla formazione e l'evoluzione
dei sistemi planetari,
all'epoca ovviamente basate
sull'unico sistema planetario noto,
cioè il nostro.
Quindi, un cambio radicale di prospettiva:
Come dice la canzone "Erase and Rewind",
gli astronomi hanno dovuto incominciare
completamente da capo,
perché da una scoperta fatta un po',
diciamo quasi per caso,
abbiamo scoperto il primo esopianeta,
e quindi - wow!
Però non sapevamo assolutamente
spiegarcene l'esistenza.
Perché 51 Pegasi B,
che è un gigante gassoso,
deve essersi formato lontano dalla stella;
e invece, era così vicino
che non potevamo sapere
come ci fosse arrivato -
Ops!
Quindi, 51 Pegasi B costrinse
a un nuovo modo di pensare.
Era appunto un gigante gassoso,
così vicino che è stato chiamato
"Hot Jupiter", cioè gioviano caldo.
Un esopianeta, quindi, il cui anno
dura quattro giorni e mezzo.
A paragone, quello di Mercurio
dura 88 giorni;
e noi, la Terra, facciamo un giro in 365.
Quindi proprio una novità estrema.
Da questo momento in poi
abbiamo scoperto oltre 5200 esopianeti
orbitare intorno a stelle
più o meno simili al nostro Sole,
nella nostra galassia.
Direi quasi nel nostro giardino galattico,
perché abbiamo possibilità di scoprirli
solo vicino a noi.
Ma più pianeti scoprivamo,
maggiore era la diversità che osservavamo
e nuove sorprese,
ogni giorno, ci attendevano.
Abbiamo scoperto, praticamente,
pianeti così piccoli e così densi
da essere fatti interamente di ferro;
oppure pianeti giganti gassosi,
così leggeri da avere, praticamente,
la consistenza dello zucchero filato.
Abbiamo scoperto mondi di ghiaccio
simili a Encelado,
una delle lune di Saturno;
o mondi di lava gorgogliante,
come Io, una delle lune di Giove.
Abbiamo scoperto degli esopianeti
grandi come delle stelle;
abbiamo scoperto degli esopianeti
intorno a delle stelle
binarie, come Tatooine.
In Kepler 16 b, per esempio.
come su Tatooine, voi avreste due ombre.
Abbiamo scoperto degli esopianeti
intorno a sistemi multiplanetari,
come Trappist uno,
che conta sette pianeti rocciosi
simili alla Terra,
e alcuni potenzialmente abitabili.
Abbiamo trovato degli esopianeti
intorno a delle stelle zombie,
cioè delle stelle che hanno finito.
Il loro ciclo vita.
E più guardavamo,
più scoprivamo esopianeti
in ogni luogo in cui volgevamo lo sguardo.
E questa storia continua tutt'oggi
con delle scoperte inaspettate,
quotidianamente.
Ma all'inizio vi avevo parlato un pochino
della possibilità di scoprire la vita:
quindi, torniamo un pochino
a questo concetto
di scoprire la vita nell'Universo,
e pensiamo alla capacità che ci regalano
le nuove tecnologie, e i nuovi avanzamenti
che adesso possiamo avere,
di capire di cosa sono fatti
questi esopianeti.
Grazie a delle tecnologie
particolarmente avanzate,
siamo in grado di osservare l'atmosfera
che fa parte di questi pianeti:
tramite la luce del sole, che passa
attraverso l'atmosfera del pianeta,
noi possiamo capire
di cosa è composta quell'atmosfera,
cosa che è fondamentale per capire
se c'è la vita su quel pianeta.
È possibile, per esempio,
che ci sia del metano;
e quindi che quell'atmosfera,
su quel pianeta,
abbia un odore di uova marce -
non bellissimo;
oppure di broccoli,
come hanno pubblicato qualche giorno fa.
A luglio scorso,
uno dei dei primi regali di questo anno
ce l'ha fatto il James Webb
Space Telescope.
Un telescopio che è stato lanciato
il 25 dicembre scorso:
un regalo pazzesco
per tutti gli astronomi.
E ha rilevato, pensate,
la molecola del biossido di carbonio,
cioè la famosa CO2,
nell'atmosfera di Wasp 39 B:
un pianeta la cui scoperta
porta la mia firma.
Ora, cosa ci aspetta nel futuro?
James Webb, come vi raccontavo,
sta regalando delle grandissime immagini:
non solo belle dal punto
di vista estetico,
ma con una capacità informativa pazzesca.
E nel 2026, la sonda
dell'Agenzia Spaziale Europea, Plato,
partirà alla caccia
di un gemello terrestre:
una Terra 2.0, un pianeta piccolo,
roccioso come la Terra,
che si trovi alla stessa distanza
della Terra dal Sole:
e quindi, che permetta di avere acqua
allo stato liquido sulla sua superficie,
condizione per la quale noi sappiamo,
sul nostro pianeta, esserci la vita.
Ma voglio fare una riflessione con voi.
Ora pensate di essere
in una notte d'estate al mare,
e che state passeggiando.
Ora vi chinate e prendete,
tra le vostre due dita,
un piccolo granello di sabbia.
Prendete questo granello di sabbia
e puntatelo al cielo, in una zona oscura.
In quel minuscolo granello di sabbia
che voi state tenendo tra le mani,
ci sono migliaia di stelle e di galassie;
e questo ce l'ha rivelato
il telescopio Hubble,
il famoso telescopio
che ora, praticamente,
è stato sostituito, quasi,
a livello tecnologico
dal James Webb.
Il James Webb, puntando
lo stesso campo di osservazione,
ci ha regalato -
Fu come per un miope - penso che
i miopi qui in sala mi capiscono -
mettere un nuovo paio di occhiali
quando il vecchio non è più sufficiente:
proprio regala una nuova visione,
una profondità di campo,
una quantità di dettagli
prima assolutamente non rilevabile.
In quell'immagine
del James Webb Space Telescope,
che potete trovare online ovunque,
del "deep field"
ci sono delle galassie che hanno
oltre 13 miliardi e mezzo di anni,
cioè delle galassie che si sono formate
all'incirca 200.000 anni dopo il Big Bang.
Ecco, vi ricordo
che questa storia è partita
dal granello di sabbia
che voi tenete nelle mani.
Pensate che nella
nostra galassia, la "Via Lattea",
si stima che ci siano
tra i 200 e i 400 miliardi di stelle.
Ognuna di esse ha almeno un pianeta:
e in quel piccolo granello di sabbia,
ci sono milioni di stelle
e migliaia di galassie,
che voi tenete fra le dita.
Quindi, vi lascio immaginare
la vastità della possibilità
della vita nel cosmo.
Pazzesca.
Ma - c'è un ma. E prima di lasciarvi,
voglio fare questa riflessione.
Molto spesso si parla degli esopianeti
come di una possibile
seconda meta per l'umanità.
Bene, se voi pensate di poter andare -
benché andare su Marte, sulla Luna,
sia un sforzo tecnologico
assolutamente necessario e fondamentale,
per poter procedere nella ricerca,
se pensate di poter andare
nello esopianeta più vicino
al sistema solare,
quindi quello che potenzialmente
potrebbe essere più abbordabile,
cioè Proxima b, che dista
quattro anni luce da noi,
significa affrontare
un viaggio di 70.000 anni.
Quindi, si impone una riflessione
[sul perché cerchiamo]
di studiare questi esopianeti.
Il motivo non è cercare
una seconda casa per l'umanità;
ma piuttosto, quello di riflettere
sull'unicità del nostro sistema solare.
E della terra!
Perché in questo momento,
noi siamo l'unico pianeta abitabile,
cioè che si trova
a una distanza dalla stella
che permette di avere acqua
allo stato liquido sulla superficie,
che è anche abitato,
cioè che sostiene la vita.
Quindi, alla fine dei conti,
forse è meglio proteggere questa unicità:
perché al momento, "There is no Planet B".
(Applausi)